in systems governed exclusively by
gravity objects farthest away from the
center would take the longest to
complete an orbit but in many galaxies
stars on the outside are orbiting at
almost the same rate as those in the
core
it's almost like a phonograph record
every part of that record spins around
like a solid disk
the stars are going too fast to stay
bound to the gravity of the galaxy they
should just fly right off into
physicists come up with an explanation
galaxies sit in a giant halo or ball of
invisible dark matter
and it's that extra mass that allows the
stars to turn fast all the way out to
the galactic rim
think about actually taking a disc of
dough and spinning it to make a pizza
the more you spin it the more those
outer regions go farther and farther
away eventually the dough just goes
flying everywhere that's what would
happen to a galaxy if it weren't for
dark matter but as you spin pizza dough
and you spin it faster and faster it
does hold itself together because
there's all this yummy gluten that's
that's acting as a glue dark matter is
the gluten of our universe
by calculating the mass needed to bind
those speeding outer stars to the galaxy
physicists are able to estimate how much
visible matter there is compared to dark
matter the results are staggering
all the stuff we thought existed was
just maybe 15 percent of our universe
that's like if you go to a restaurant
and realize the measly 15 tip you know
that's all we are
we're not even the majority substance
we may not be able to see it but dark
matter makes up some 85
of all matter
wherever we look we can see its gravity
having effects
it glues galaxies like our milky way
together
and a close look reveals dark matter
can also bend light itself
it's called gravitational lensing
and massive object can bend space and
time and light must follow the curves of
that space and time
gigantic clumps of any matter create a
gravitational lens
dark matter showed its space warping
power in a trick it played with a
gigantic explosion in a far-off galaxy
cluster
supernova repstall was first detected in
november of 2014.
supernova refstall is actually one of my
favorite recent results in all of the
astronomical literature that that result
blew me away so a star explodes light is
emitted in all directions and some of it
makes its way towards the earth so far
so good this is very standard so the
flash appears
and then another flash appears
we see it again
and again
and again
we see the explosion go off in four
parts of the sky and then a year later a
fifth explosion goes off in a totally
different part of the sky
what's going on
analysis proves that these multiple
explosions are the same supernova
but between this one dying star and our
telescopes sits a giant mass of dark
matter
a huge gravitational lens
what that means is that some of these
rays of light will take much longer more
complicated paths through this region of
spacetime
the dark matter lens turns one supernova
into a fireworks display lasting an
entire year
dark matter affected the trajectory of
light from the supernova so much that
for some of those trajectories
it added a whole light here
it took a whole extra year for light to
reach us
something is very definitely out there
distorting our view of the cosmos
it's a potent clue
the dark matter is real
now new evidence suggests that without
it we might not exist at all
the cosmos is filled with an unseen
substance
its mass even bends starlight
gravitational lensing suggests dark
matter holds our entire universe
together
for decades this specter of space
has haunted us
we've never been able to pin it down
in 2021 an international team ran a
virtual experiment to try to predict
where dark matter should be by letting
computers map out where we think it
lives
because we think we know how it behaves
we can model what it should be doing in
supercomputer simulations
the team taught the computer how dark
matter bends light
then applied computational power to 17
000 unexplored galaxies
the model created a dark matter map
i think a lot of people when they
imagine the universe on the larger
scales think it's sort of boring
everything's uniform but that's not what
we see
what's amazing is that on the larger
scales of the universe we see a very
particular pattern
when we zoom out we see this magnificent
structure this cosmic web that's created
by dark matter
the interweaving tendrils of dark matter
stretch for thousands of light years
across the cosmos
at the junctions where matter is
concentrated
we find galaxies form illuminating the
dark scaffold
if dark matter exists scientists believe
it makes up 85 percent of the matter in
the universe and also controls the
remaining 15 percent
regular matter like stars planets
us
if they're right
dark matter played a critical role in
actually building the universe we see
today
2021
astronomers using the sky mapper
observatory in australia train
specialist optics on a dwarf galaxy
called tucana ii
the sky mapper's filters split up the
starlight into a spectrum of wavelengths
revealing
some very ancient
light
one of the best clocks that we can put
on the universe
is the progress of chemistry
right
the build up of more complex elements
over time
stars are nothing if not factories of
chemical complexity they slam uh
particles together and create heavier
elements right through a process called
fusion the later the generation of star
the more chemically complex it is tucana
two's spectral signature reveals its
stars contain very few of these heavy
complex elements
a clue that lets astrophysicists
calculate the age of the galaxy
these are very very old stars from the
very early days of the universe when
the gas in the universe was not that
chemically complex
tucana 2 might be one of the oldest
known structures that we can see in our
local universe
it could be as old as 13 billion years
almost as old as the universe itself
this grand old lady of a galaxy is a
tiny thing barely 3 000 stars
and yet way out on her galactic rim
stars hurtle around at breakneck speed
when you look at the mass of this ultra
faint dwarf galaxy it only has a few
thousand times the mass of the sun
that's really small and at the speed
it's moving it should fly apart
tucana two doesn't break up because it's
glued together
apparently by an incredible amount of
dark matter
when you look at a galaxy like our milky
way it's about 85 percent dark matter
which is a lot but with tucana 2 it's
more like 99 percent
tucana 2 is old among the oldest
galaxies in the universe and it is
packed full of dark matter
simulations suggest this dark matter
played a key role in shaping tucana two
and other very early galaxies right from
the beginning
gathering regular matter into clumps and
building the first galaxies
the importance of dark matter really
can't be overstated it has actually
controlled the way matter has evolved
since the beginning of the universe it
brings matter together you need this
underlying structure of dark matter to
make it all happen
[Music]
scientists think that for billions of
years as the early universe grew
dark matter called the shots
without its gravity structures like the
milky way wouldn't have formed
[Music]
we've seen dark matter's light bending
effects
we've even deduced where it should be
dark matter really does appear to exist
but this evidence is indirect
circumstantial
to get conclusive proof the dark matter
exists don't we need to find some
[Music]
if we could find a lump of dark matter
um that would be one of the greatest
discoveries in all of nature in all of
in all of our history right because we
would understand one of the most
fundamental components for how our
universe works
dropping the title they love that
it's time to hunt for dark matter itself
could it be hiding
in the darkest place of all
[Music]
black holes
you